lay
Lift Me Up
oh
hold me down
Rihanna's first single in six years is
out and the Navy may have to grab some
tissues for this one
I know how to make it work the singer
dropped lift me up on Friday the lead
single from Black Panther wakanda
forever which honors The Life and Legacy
of late actor Chadwick Boseman
you know we loved him we we know that
you love him and we would not we will
honor that we honor it for the fans as
well as for ourselves the moving ballad
begins with Riri humming the melody
before she launches into this emotional
chorus
Lift Me Up
oh
me down
keep keep me close
and Rihanna's next verses make the
homage to Chadwick very clear
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
[Music]
the song's release comes one day after
the Grammy winner made her red carpet
return at the sequels premiere
it was a special moment I think it's the
end of the year I think it's big for me
as well I mean
I'm honored to be a part of this as for
black panther director Ryan coogler he's
not sure how he got Rihanna to make this
musical moment happen but he's happy she
did it she's a a person who marches to
be the wrong drum I'm just thankful that
she she wanted to she wanted to
contribute to this you know and I'll be
forever grateful and and not just her
you know but all of the other fantastic
musicians that that are on the
soundtrack but but she is a big one man
she is she is the one and only and don't
worry the Navy should be expecting
another single from Riri soon because
she has two tracks on the film
soundtrack the second is titled Born
Again In the meantime we'll be playing
this one on repeat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we we need love